es ist nichts da was man sozusagen
verteilen könnte jetzt haben wir 100
millionen 9 milliarden programm das
umgesetzt wird das dauert jahre die
fehler der vergangenheit kann man eben
leider nicht so schnell korrigieren wie
wir auch die fehler in der
energiepolitik nicht innerhalb von
wenigen wochen quellen sagen wollen dass
wenn man die waffen liefern könnte ja
natürlich muss man auch sehen dass auf
der anderen seite haben wir jetzt
festgestellt ein irrationaler diktator
ist ja und das risiko hat mit sicherheit
olaf scholz jeden tag abzuwägen wie weit
habe ich schaden vom deutschen volk
abzuwenden das ist artikel 56 der
deutschen verfassung nicht er hat ja
nicht auf die ukrainische verfassung
sein alt geleitet sondern auch die
deutsche verfassung ich finde wir müssen
auch irgendwann mal sehen dass wir in
einer selbst geschaffenen
zwangssituation sind wir sind erpressbar
geworden und das ist nicht mit starken
worten einfach vom tisch zu fegen das
ist so
[Musik]